نادي يوفنتوس الايطالي يتعرض لعقوبه جديده
عيد ميلاد ارجيفين يدخل ارسنال في ورطه
ومندش يصف رونالدو بالافضل في تاريخ كره
القدم
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
اصدرت المحكمه الرياضيه في ايطاليا حكما
جديدا ضد يوفنتوس بخصوص قضيه مناوره
الرواتب وقررت المحكمه توقيع غرامه قدرها
700 الف يورو على نادي دون خصم نقاط
والاكتفاء بالنقاط العشر التي سحبت منه
سابقا وكانت اداره يوفي قد توصلت لاتفاقا
مع المدعي العام للاتحاد يتضمن الاعتراف
بمخالفات المدراء السابقين والتخلي عن
الاستئناف مقابل الحصول على عقوبه مخففه
بعد مرور يوم على وجود في العنايه المركزه
نشرت زوجه سيرجيوريكو حارس فريق سان
جيرمان عبر حساب على الانستغرام رساله دعم
لزوجها وشكر للجماهير المتعاطفه مع سيرجيو
بعد اصطدام حصان وعربته بالحارس الاسباني
كما ذكرت صحيفه ماركه بان ريكو كان يقود
هو الاخر حصانا في الحدث السنوي الذي يقام
جنوب اسبانيا واضافت اسره اللاعب في بيان
الله على السوشيال ميديا لانها تنتظر
نتائج الطبيه خلال الساعات القليله
المقبله
اعتادت الانديه على الاحتفال بعيد ميلاد
نجومها السابقين عبر حسابات على السوشيال
ميديا ونادي ارسنال احتفل بدوره بعيد
ميلاد نجمه السابق الروسي اندري ارجافين
قبل ان يحذفها سبب الهجوم بسبب الهجوم
الذي تلقه من المتابعين الاوكرانيين او من
الانجليز المتعاطفين مع كييف خاصه وان
ابدى في وقت سابق استعداده للمشاركه في
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مدح و كل اللاعبين الشهير النجمه
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو واصفا اياه
بافضل لاعب في تاريخ كره القدم وقال في
تصريحات ابرزتها صحيفه
بان رونالدو هو افضل السفير للبرتغال
وعلينا ان نكون ممتنين لكل ما قدمه في
عالم كره القدم لقد كان ولا يزال الافضل
في تاريخ اللعبه
[موسيقى]